time now when you're when you're
measuring people's health and when
you're measuring people's health in
regard to how much sleep they have like
what how do you how do you do that do
you just talk to people do you do
surveys like how do you get like a
detailed analysis of people's patterns
so you can do it at many different
levels I mean we can start at the sort
of gross high level which is
epidemiological studies across millions
of people where you do surveys you ask
them about their sleep and then you look
at health outcomes
the first thing from that data that's
clear is an unfortunate truth the
shorter your sleep the shorter your life
well short sleep predicts all cause
mortality which is really ironic because
people that want to sleep less I like
you know I don't have a whole lot of
time you know this life is short
yes [ __ ] shorter if you sleep less
yeah that's that old maxim you know you
can sleep when you're dead
yeah well it's mortally unwise advice
because we know from the data you will
be both dead sooner and the quality of
that now shorter life will be
significantly worse
yeah that's counterintuitive to people
the idea that you need this it's not
just like you're making best use of time
by sleeping less you're not you would
make best use of time by being awake
less exactly which is crazy
I mean wakefulness firstly from a brain
perspective is a low-level brain damage
we know that wakefulness is yeah low
like right now we're you and I are
getting low-level brain damage yep
that's right and it's sleep that offers
a repair 'try function
Wow and you know I'll give you one
example which is your risk for
Alzheimer's disease insufficient sleep
across the lifespan now seems to be one
of the most significant lifestyle
factors determining whether or not
you'll develop Alzheimer's what studies
or if any have been done on people that
work third shift so people have looked
at shift work in general they haven't
necessarily split it down to that
granular point but what we see is that
shift workers have higher rates of
obesity high rates of diabetes but
perhaps most frightening Lee cancer and
in fact we now know the link between a
lack of sleep and cancer is quite strong
insufficient sleep is linked to cancer
of the bowel cancer of the prostate
cancer of the
and the association has become so
powerful that recently the World Health
Organization decided to classify any
form of nighttime shift work as a
probable carcinogen whoa yeah so jobs
that may induce cancer because of a
disruption of your sleep wake rhythms
are there other correlating factors like
don't people that sleep less or work
into the night don't they eat more and
eat more shitty food they do both of
those things yeah and we know exactly
the pathway so there are two hormones
that control your appetite and your
weight and one is called leptin the
other is called ghrelin they sound like
hobbits but they're not the real homer
the real chemical leptin is the chemical
that tells your brain you're full you're
satiated you don't want to eat anymore
ghrelin does the opposite it's the
hunger hormone it says you want to eat
more you're not satisfied with your food
if I take people and these studies have
been done we've done some of these
studies too and you just put you a group
of healthy people on four or five hours
of sleep for let's say one week and you
look at those two hormones they go and
in fortunately opposite directions so
leptin that says you're full stop eating
that gets suppressed by a lack of sleep
ghrelin the hunger hormone that gets
ramped up so firstly people who are
sleeping just 5 to 6 hours a night will
on average eat somewhere between 200 to
300 extra calories each day because of
the underslept state add that up it's
about 70,000 extra calories a year it's
about 10 to 15 pounds of obese mass each
year which for me is starting to sound
familiar but what we also know is that
it's not just that when you're
underslept
you eat more you eat more of the wrong
things hmm so if and this the great
scientific work if you give people this
sort of finger buffet and they can eat
whatever they want and it contains all
of the different food groups and you
sleep deprived them or you give them a
full eight hours of sleep yes they start
to overeat by somewhere around about 450
calories with total sleep deprivation
but what they go after is
heavy-hitting carbohydrates and simple
sugars processed food and they stay away
from the healthy sort of leafy greens
nuts proteins etc hmm so you're not just
eating more you're eating more of the
wrong things and that's why a lack of
sleep has such a strong obesogenic
profile to it and you can take a step
back too and you say well if you look at
the rise of obesity over the past
seventy years just this upward
exponential increase and if you plot on
the same graph the amount of sleep that
society is getting it goes in the
opposite direction as sleep time has
declined obesity rates have increased
I'm not going to sit here and tell you
that the obesity epidemic is simply a
sleep problem it's not it's a problem of
us being sedentary processed foods
larger food serving sizes if you take
those factors though by themselves they
cannot explain the increase in obesity
other things are at play is sleep one of
them now we know it is it's a critical
factor in the obesogenic epidemic I know
from personal experience when I'm tired
I always gravitate towards the worst
choices it's it for me it's late-night
cheeseburgers yeah you know Wendy's at
two o'clock in the morning or whatever